peut être une réserve est un autre grand
et beau pays
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue pour deux
heures d'émission nous décrypterons
comme chaque soir du lundi au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités et nos reporters sur le terrain
tout de suite les grands titres de
l'actualité de ce jeudi 24 septembre
2001 l'union européenne appelle les
états membres à durcir les mesures façon
qu vide et c'est chose faite en france
mais les restrictions annoncées hier par
olivier ferrand provoque incompréhension
et colère surtout dans la région de
marseille placée en alerte maximale
le président de la région provence alpes
côte d'azur renaud muselier annonce
déposé un référé contre les nouvelles
mesures
l union européenne les pays baltes la
pologne les états unis tous ont affirmé
ne pas reconnaître
alexandre loukachenko est la décision
intervient au lendemain de la cérémonie
d'investiture du président biélorusse
est sa réélection controversée le 9 août
dernier a déclenché un mouvement de
contestation inédit dans le pays
[Musique]
à l'assemblée générale de l'onu se
poursuit toujours par visioconférence et
parmi les demandes des chefs d'état une
revient régulièrement celle de la
réforme du conseil de sécurité mais pas
d'avancer en vue dans ce domaine la
journée a été notamment marquée par la
prise de parole du président de la côte
d'ivoire
ils demandent une aide économique pour
l'afrique pour surmonter la crise
sanitaire à la côte d'ivoire secouée par
des tensions grandissantes à la proche
de la présidentielle une situation qui
préoccupe le
[Musique]
sans atteindre le niveau de mars dernier
plusieurs indicateurs montrent que
l'épidémie est reparti à la hausse le
gouvernement a durci le ton avec de
nouvelles mesures restrictives avancée
par olivier ferrand
la nouvelle cartographie de l'épidémie
montre que le pays n'est pas logé à la
même enseigne selon les zones
paris passe en zone d' alerte renforcée
tout comme lille ou encore bordeaux
les rassemblements de plus de dix
personnes seront interdits dans les
espaces publics les bars et restaurants
devront fermer à 22h dès lundi plus
grave les zones placées en alerte
maximale à maximales elles sont au
nombre de deux elle la métropole
d'aix-marseille et la guadeloupe
sur place la fermeture des bars et
restaurants est totale et cela rentre en
vigueur dès samedi
une mesure que beaucoup ne comprennent
pas regarder la situation assez
tellement dégradée que effectivement il
y a un jour où il faut prendre des
décisions plus drastiques et c'est je
vous avouerai que c'est d'ailleurs pour
ça qu'on est sorti ce soit on s'est dit
est ce qu'on va avoir d'autres
l'occasion d'aller au resto d'ici les 15
jours à venir donc on s'est fait un
petit plateau de coquillages
personnellement je pense que c'est
désolant de fermer les restaurants et
les bars parce que c'est quand même
un aspect économique important dans
notre pays et ça va commencer à bloquer
toute l'économie parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de choses qui sont derrière il n'y a pas
que les restaurants et les bars mais il
ya tout ce qui des aliments etc
c'était très pénible pendant confinement
aujourd'hui le démarrage est très
compliqué
rajouter une couche supplémentaire je
pense qu'on va fermer beaucoup de
boutiques
beaucoup de restaurants à raison de
cette décision et les élus eux aussi
sont en colère contre ces fermetures il
demande un délai c'est le cas du premier
adjoint de la mer benoît payant avec
madame la maire je demande au
gouvernement dix jours avant la mise en
place de nouvelles mesures si à la fin
de la semaine prochaine les indicateurs
repartent à la hausse
nous serons prêts à prendre les
décisions qui s'imposent et qui seront
alors comprise par tout le monde
personne ne veut entamer un bras de
force avec le gouvernement la maire de
marseille n'a aucune intention de baston
avec le gouvernement nous nous battons
non pas avec le gouvernement nous
voulons discuter je ne souhaite pas les
faire reculer nous demandons simplement
un gel de la décision pour qu'ensemble
nous puissions prendre les meilleures
décisions
alors on l'a constaté toute la journée
les mesures du gouvernement selon les
territoires ont fait couler beaucoup
d'encre avant leur mise en application
avec une situation sanitaire qui elle
continue de se dégrader
il en va en parler tout de suite avec
nos invités
[Musique]
nous ont rejoints ce soir pour partager
leurs analyses
alexis poulain éditorialistes bonsoir
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france avec nous également stéphane
ravier président du groupe rassemblement
national au conseil municipal de
marseille merci à vous à vos côtés
christophe prudhomme porte parole de
l'association des médecins urgentistes
de france bonsoir on sera alors c'est
donc messieurs l'incompréhension à
marseille après l annonce de la
fermeture totale des bars et des
restaurants
et c'est même la colère chez les
professionnels chez les habitants mais
aussi chez les politiques le président
de la région paca renaud muselier a
annoncé le dépôt demain d'un
référé-liberté en justice pour empêcher
la fermeture des bars et restaurants de
la métropole
aix marseille est-ce que vous saluer la
démarche stéphane ravier
je participerai demain au rassemblement
à l'appel des professionnels de la
restauration parce qu'effectivement trop
c'est trop les les décisions aussi
soudaine que violente venus de paris et
qui s'abat sur marseille comme ça qui
punit marseille qui punit l'emploi qui
punit les restaurateurs parce que
monsieur verra manifestement s'affolent
monsieur vers ans qui préfère ouvrir le
non seulement le parapluie mais le
paratonnerre et le para judiciaires il
ne veut pas se retrouver sans doute
devant les tribunaux avec son
incompétence surlendemain de son
incompétence et de son et près de son
impréparation pardon lors de la première
vague donc aujourd'hui prend des mesures
coercitives violente sans en informer
sans dialoguer avec les élus de
marseille et sur l'ensemble de la
métropole parce qu'il y à 92 communes du
département qui sont touchés par ces par
ses décisions unilatérales et ça serait
le coup de grâce le coup de grâce pour
de trop nombreux restaurateurs on ne
peut que s'y opposer
christophe prudhomme je rappelle que
vous êtes porte parole de l'association
des médecins urgentistes de france il ya
la guerre des chiffres aussi qui enfin
en ce qui concerne marseille entre un
gouvernement qui lui pointe retour local
d'incidence du commis de 19
et puis les locaux qui assure que
l'équipe
que l'épidémie commence à décroître
christophe prudhomme en tant que médecin
ces mesures est ce qu'elles sont
indispensables aujourd'hui même si
l'épidémie commence à décroître
quel est votre regard sur cette
situation il ya clairement il ya
clairement une erreur politique
les mesures de santé publique ne sont
bonnes que quand elles sont acceptées
par la population
ce que vous avez deux stratégies en
termes de santé publique soit la
coercition brutale c'est la méthode
chinoise qui est très efficace mais qui
est plus acceptable chez nous ou alors
il faut gagner la confiance de la
population or là le gouvernement ferait
tout son contraire et attise les
contradictions les mesures ne sont pas
comprises elles veulent le gouvernement
va les appliquer de manière autoritaire
donc c'est complètement contre productif
en termes de santé publique
par ailleurs vous savez le problème
aujourd'hui pour nous professionnels de
santé
c'est pas un afflux de malades c'est que
le gouvernement n'a rien fait pendant
les quatre mois de répit que nous a
laissé l'épidémie pour augmenter les
lits dans les hôpitaux
donc aujourd'hui les hôpitaux ne sont
pas en capacité de gérer les patients
classiques qui ont rempli les hôpitaux
parce qu'on les a laissés à l'abandon
pendant trois mois et nous avions déjà
un suffisamment de lits de réanimation
pour les prendre en charge
depuis des années mais non sont le
manque de lits de réanimation donc les
quelques dizaines de malades
supplémentaires qui arrive aujourd'hui
et qui ont besoin de leur animation et
qui sans atteindre la comique 19 et bien
créé une situation de tension et de
crise mais qui était prévisible depuis
plusieurs mois nous disons ils font
réellement embaucher massivement dans
les hôpitaux pour ouvrir des lits et
l'élite père elle pas comme dit le
ministre de la santé des lices
saisonniers voyez ouvrir des lits quand
tu es malade sont en attente on
d'urgence eh bien écoutez c'est une
erreur politique parce que moi ce que
j'attends des politiques
gérer c'est prévoir et c'est pas prendre
des mesures en urgence et surtout de
prendre des mesures avec des virages à
180 degrés incompréhensible pour la
population et puis pour terminer vous
savez je viens d'avoir les chiffres
concernant marseille comment
mes collègues des hôpitaux de l'ap-hm
alors ils sont en baisse et pas à
écouter ils sont stables pour l'instant
ils sont stables
c'est à dire que nous avons depuis
maintenant quelques semaines n'ont pas
une deuxième vague mais une arrivée de
patience aliments hautement s'abaisse
quelques jours ça réellement ce qui est
clair c'est qu'il va falloir apprendre à
vivre avec l'épidémie et avec un nombre
de malades conséquent atteint de
l'acolyte 19 pendant les mois qui
viennent et pendant peut-être les années
qui viennent donc l'urgence aujourd'hui
l'urgence aujourd'hui c'est un que les
gens puissent se faire tester colons
résultats dans la journée pour pouvoir
s'isoler
parce que là c'est l'incurie la plus
totale depuis plusieurs mois et 2 il
faut augmenter massivement les capacités
hospitalières en embauchant massivement
dans les hôpitaux
voilà ce sont les deux mesures
essentielles et toutes les querelles qui
existent aujourd'hui avec des mesures
qui sont incomprises par la population
et bien créé quoi des situations qui
vont être pire
voyez pire que ce qu'on veut prévenir
fermer les bars et les restaurants mais
les gens vont se réunir chez eux sans
aucune protection
parce qu'on va pas envoyer les policiers
pour frapper à la porte et pour voir si
des gens sont à distance
et puis quand même à marseille à
marseille qui est une ville du sud à moi
je suis plutôt dans le nord
mais écoutez quand vous êtes sur une
terrasse les risques de contamination
quand vous êtes en milieu ouvert sont
très limités donc utilisons les
terrasses temps qu'ils font qui fait
beau évitons effectivement que les
restaurants et bien utiliser les espaces
intérieurs
ça ce sont des mesures intelligentes
mais fermé brutalement les restaurants
c'est complètement contre-productif
c'est comme effectivement ne pas
autoriser les jeunes à faire un petit
peu la fête tout en respectant un
certain nombre de règles
on va interdire c'est provoquer des
réactions contrepoint du team en termes
de santé publique des querelles
effectivement et une passe d'armes
aujourd'hui via les réseaux sociaux
entre le président de la région paca
renaud muselier et le ministre de la
santé on regarde et je vous donne la
parole après l'exploit j'apprends avec
étonnement et colère une décision pour
laquelle la mairie de marseille n'a pas
été consultée
rien dans la situation sanitaire ne
justifie cette annonce
je n'accepte pas que les marseillais
soient victimes de décisions
politique que personne ne peut
comprendre les décisions annoncées ce
soir dont je mesure la portée pour les
marseillais vise précisément à la
protéger alors que tous les indicateurs
sanitaires sont très dégradées ce dont
je me suis entretenu cette après midi
avec votre premier adjoint et le
président renaud muselier un coup de
téléphone n'est pas une concertation
olivier ferrand quand l'appel est passé
à 18h30 pour une intervention à 19h dans
la précipitation
cette décision est unilatérale inadaptée
et injuste
vous pensez être courageux en fait vous
perdez votre sang froid
alexis poulain qu'est ce que vous
observez dans cette passe d'armes
c'est une perte de sang froid du
gouvernement comme le souligne renaud
muselier
c'est surtout la même un préparation la
même unité dans la gestion de cette
crise sanitaire depuis mars
rien n'a été fait rien a été appris les
lits qui aurait dû être pérennisé ouvert
les médecins qui auraient dû être
embauchés les soignants qui aurait dû
être embauchés tout ça n'a pas existé
la rentrée qui aurait dû être préparés
dans le discours d'olivier ferrand hier
il n'y avait aucune mention des écoles
des universités qui ont été seuls à
gérer l'afflux massif d'écoliers et
d'étudiants dans des lieux où bien sûr
la s'échanger à nouveau le virus
l'impréparation de ce gouvernement elle
est inédite
elle est incroyable et il voudrait que
ce soit la faute des français ils
voudraient que la culpabilité de cette
crise sanitaire soit entièrement sur le
dos des français qui sont trop bêtes
pour comprendre qu'ils sont trop
indisciplinés pour mettre leurs masques
qui font n'importe quoi c'est faux les
français je trouve ils sont extrêmement
patients ils sont extrêmement calme avec
ce gouvernement qui tient je ne sais pas
comment parce que là on a affaire à une
gestion politique de la crise qui n'a
rien à voir avec d'effets sanitaires
moi j'aimerais savoir quand on parle de
réanimation en réalité combien de
personnes sont intubés aujourd'hui
qu'est ce que c'est que ces chiffres on
n'a pas les chiffres
quand vous avez vendredi des chiffres
qui arrive on a 300 morts qui
disparaissent le lendemain parce que
finalement il ya eu une erreur de
comptage qu'elle quel crédit peut-on
donner au chiffre monté par les rs
aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il se passe dans les systèmes
d'urgence je sais que les médecins se
font leur travail mais que fait le
gouvernement pour les aider
rappelez-vous la première vague les
médecins demandait des masques de la
prod et des outils de protection des
moyens on les applaudit c'est tous les
soirs à la fenêtre
les moyens sont arrivés beaucoup trop
tard il ya eu des morts au sein des du
personnel soignant ne l'oublions pas il
ya eu les mots de l'aveyron qui disait
que le masque était inutile à l'époque
il y à toute la chaîne des tests
aujourd'hui qui ne fonctionne pas parce
que on manque de réactifs parce qu'on
n'a pas su organiser cette chaîne de
test alors je veux bien qu'on est
maintenant monsieur bayrou à la
planification de la relance mais il
faudrait peut-être une planification de
la gestion sanitaire
aujourd'hui c'est du grand n'importe
quoi une improvisation permanente de la
part du gouvernement qui veut se
défausser de ses responsabilités sur les
responsables politiques à l'échelon
territorial régional local municipal
cela se rebelle
ils ont raison et je les trouve encore
gentil dans leur rébellion parce que
renaud muselier a raison d'essayer de
tout faire pour arrêter ce délire
politique parce que ce n'est pas du tout
scientifique bien sûr que les
restaurants n'ont pas être montrés du
doigt ils ont mis en place des mesures
d'accueil
iliad était il ya des terrasses et des
espaces ouverts également cédé lieu de
convivialité
pourquoi le virus ne serait dangereux
que dans les lieux de convivialité les
rassemblements familiaux alors que dans
les universités bond et on n'en parle
pas olivier derand c'est bien là le
l'objet de ne pas en parler
volontairement donc cette gestion
politique elle est lamentable
il faut le dire et je trouve que
l'opposition politique reste bien en
deçà de ce qu'elle pourrait faire parce
que là on rentre dans quelque chose qui
est du domaine pour moi du virtuel de la
science fiction
or la science existe ce virus est bien
il a un taux de létalité qui est certes
sévère mais qu'elle est quand même pas
non plus quelque chose qui demande à
sans arrêt demandez aux gens de rester
chez eux confinés comme comme on est en
train petit à petit de remettre des
petits cailloux
parce que si ça continue comme ça bien
vous pouvez oublier noël et le jour de
l'an à la fin de l'année et aucune
mesure en face pour réellement aider
ceux qui en ont besoin
les soignants les gens qui accueillent
du public que ce soit dans les écoles ou
ailleurs les restaurateurs alors on va
encore bono le maire l'a dit faire des
mesures économiques pour aider les
restaurateurs mais les restaurateurs ils
veulent pas d dz il
le faire leur travail tout simplement
continuer de servir des gens et des
lieux de convivialité
parce que ça suffit de vouloir à tout
prix enfermer les gens chez eux et ne
les fait ressortir que pour travailler
dans des transports bondé et ensuite
dans des bureaux où là encore le virus
peut circuler sans aucun problème donc
on demande de la clarté et on demande
aussi de la responsabilité de la part
des dirigeants politiques qui
aujourd'hui à paris et bien semble tout
faire pour vouloir éviter la
responsabilité christophe prudhomme
alexis paula s'est interrogé justement
sur ces chiffres est ce que vous savez
précisément vous avez des informations
sur ces chiffres
combien de personnes sont intubés est-ce
que c'est très clair et précis oui nous
avons des chiffres mais vous savez la
question c'est l'évolution dans le temps
les chiffres quotidiens y compris comme
le disait votre éditorialistes qui ne
sont pas vérifiées donc on corrige enfin
voyez nous nous sommes assez irrité de
crs qui le demande qui nous harcèle
quotidiennement pour avoir des chiffres
pour remplir des tableaux excel et je
voudrais insister sur une chose c'est
que alors que la belgique est un des
pays les plus touchés au monde beaucoup
plus que nous rapporter à la population
la première ministre belge ce matin a
dit clairement il vaut mieux des mesures
simples allégé qui sont acceptées par la
population plutôt que les mesures
contraignantes qui vont être contestées
voilà il faut que le gouvernement
comprenne qu'il a perdu la confiance de
la population des soignants et donc
cette perte de confiance rend son
discours inaudible et moi j'insiste
j'insiste sur le fait qu' aujourd'hui
effectivement il y à une reprise de
l'épidémie avec un nombre de malades qui
nationalement augmente lentement mais si
nous sommes en crise c'est parce que
nous n'avons pas armer nos hôpitaux
je rappelle que nous sommes revenus à un
nombre de lits en réanimation que l'on
considérait déjà comme insuffisants au
mois de février pour pouvoir encaisser
le pic que l'on a connu nous sommes
revenus à ses 5500 lit dans mon
département qui a des départements les
plus touchés que la seine-saint-denis
nous avons un nombre de lits aujourd'hui
ouvert qui est inférieur à celui que
nous avions l'an dernier parce qu'il
n'ya pas assez de paix
soleil nous voulions ouvrir une unité de
25 le directeur hier en réunion nous a
dit je n'arrive pas à embaucher des
infirmières voilà c'est ça la réalité
donc il ya une véritable colère
aujourd'hui chez les soignants
parce que ce discours du gouvernement
est contre productif et il s'occupe pas
des priorités que nous avons ciblé déjà
depuis plusieurs mois et surtout quand
on le dit qu'il n'a pas d'argent pour
l'hôpital mais écoutez nous avons
dépensé là je pense quasiment un
milliard et demi d'euros pour les tests
tests qui l'ont servi quasiment à rien
parce que quand vous tester les gens et
que le résultat à rennes 8 à 10 jours
après ça ne sert à rien donc les foules
et surtout dernier élément qui m'a
particulièrement c'est l' annonce par le
premier ministre lors de son
intervention il ya une huitaine de jours
qu'il allait embaucher deux mille
personnes dans les ars et à l'assurance
maladie c'est-à-dire des contrôleurs
voilà qui on embauche des contrôleurs
alors qu'on a besoin de soignants sur le
terrain pas des contrôleurs voilà donc
tout ça montre bien que il faudrait pour
une fois réellement écouté la population
leurs élus et les professionnels
voilà si on veut pouvoir avancer parce
que ce virus va être là pendant
plusieurs mois peut-être pendant
plusieurs années
il faut bien qu'on vive au quotidien
font la guerre au quotidien et pour
rassurer quand même la population oui il
ya un nombre de tests positifs
importants
le nombre de patients hospitalisés
augmente depuis quelques semaines
m'écouter le nom de mort reste
relativement limité
regardez les chiffres ce qui est
important c'est la mortalité dans sa
mortalité reste aujourd'hui une
relativement maîtrisé stéphane rasé nous
avons augmenté
nous avons amélioré nos techniques de
réanimation on a du moins les patients
et on a des traitements qui sont pas des
traitements contre le virus mais contre
les complications qui améliore qui
diminue le temps des animations et qui a
fait baisser la mortalité qui était
initialement de 30 % en réanimation à 15
% aujourd'hui
christoph weil on va on va s'interroger
effectivement sur les coudes des élus
avec vous stéphane ravier vous êtes aux
premières loges à marseille
est ce que les élus locaux ils ont été
concertés ces derniers jours cette
fermeture des bars des restaurants à ce
qu'elle avait été mis sur la table et
moi hier soir encore j'étais avec maires
des bouches du rhône et ses élus et
alors que nous évoquions la situation de
sa commune il a il a saisi son portable
parce qu'il l'a senti vibrer il a lu ce
qui apparaît c'est ce que la presse il
lui faisait savoir et bien à savoir que
le préfet avait décidé la fermeture des
bars des brasseries à partir à partir de
samedi donc il m'a regardé et m'a tendu
le téléphone et me voilà voilà
maintenant il va falloir que je me
débrouille avec ça ils n'ont été ni
consultés ni même informé avoir avant
les autres ils ont appris qu'en tout à
chacun vient la presse c'est un
véritable véritable preuve de mépris
mais je dirais que le préfet lui-même
finalement a lui aussi été pris de court
parce que avant d'être parmi vous là
messieurs ce soir il y à quelques
minutes encore j'étais en mode audio
conférence avec des parlementaires et
avec le préfet de région justement qui
nous apprenait que ce soit là alors nous
parlons et bien il n'a toujours pas
délimiter la zone des communes qui
seraient concernées par ces fermetures
alors que le ministre verra on vous
disait hier évoqué hier la zone
métropolitaine c'est à dire les 92
villes qui constitue la métropole mais
montrer une carte des bouches du rhône
qui compte elle 119 communes ont même eu
hier la communication du ministre c'est
contradictoire en fait il parlait de la
métropole en montrant une carte des
bouches-du-rhône et aujourd'hui encore
son préfet le préfet de
deux régions et bien n'a pas encore eu
le temps de de délimiter la zone donc
des communes qui seraient frappés par
les conséquences et vous le vous le
disiez messieurs de la folle europe et
de l'incompétence de ce gouvernement si
bien incarnée par monsieur virant voilà
mon année donc les élus évidemment nous
n'ont pas été informés ils sont vent
debout et je tenais à vous dire que
j'entendais que les élus étaient été
patients ils le sont de moins en moins
et les professionnels aujourd'hui en
marseille en particulier et j'imagine
qu'un ex en proie aux rentes et même
ailleurs eh bien ils sont désormais dans
une volonté je dirais donc découdre
certains annoncé qu'il ne fermerait pas
le rétablissement à ce que fermer
l'établissement pendant quinze jours
après des mois de difficultés
ça serait tiré le rideau de façon
définitive donc il ne mourront pas sur
ordre du ministre de la santé et sont
décidés à engager un bras de fer parce
qu'il s'agit tout simplement de sauver
l'emploi de sauver l'emploi de milliers
et de milliers de marseillais depuis qu
rhodanien alexis poule a on se souvient
pourtant de la volonté du gouvernement
de s'appuyer sur les territoires
justement sur les autorités sur les élus
bien pour adapter les mesures pendant
cette crise sanitaire
comment est ce que vous comprenez
finalement ce manque de dialogue
visiblement en tout cas d'après ce que
nous dit stéphane ravier entre le
gouvernement et les élus locaux et ce
manque de dialogue et il est
systématique avec ce gouvernement avec
la façon dont il gère les affaires du
pays
on fait semblant c'est le en même temps
c'est à dire qu'il ya des discours et
puis il ya des actes dans les discours
on est toujours pour la concertation
sociale quelle qu'elle soit le travail
avec les territoires ça c'est pour les
caméras ça c'est pour le discours et
faire croire que oui la raim rappelez
vous aimez le maquereau et est élu sur
le principe de bienveillance on a vu la
bienveillance à coup de deux lanceurs de
balles de défense et de grenades
lacrymogènes
donc tout le discours n'a rien à voir
avec les actes donc pour ce gouvernement
pour le juger il faut le juger sur les
actes et les actes ils parlent
d'eux-mêmes impréparation
mensonges et non concertation
enfin cette idée d'appeler une
demi-heure avant les annonces de ne pas
prévenir les élus de ce qu'il va se
passer dans leur circonscription c'est
incroyable comment peut-on après avoir
un premier ministre qui se met en avant
en disant je suis le premier ministre
des territoires il va falloir
décentralisée non on a là une vision
jacobine comme on l'a toujours eue mais
pire encore avec ce mensonge des
territoires qui fait que derrière il ne
sert qu'à une chose se défausser de la
responsabilité sur les élus locaux et si
jamais ça se passe mal eh bien ce sera
vers les mers vers les responsables de
régions vers les élus de des territoires
qu'on va se retourner en disant mais
qu'est ce que vous avez fait pourtant
consignes du gouvernement était clair et
on l'appelle discuter ensemble ça suffit
je crois que les responsables auront des
comptes à rendre
je le redis encore ici aujourd'hui il ya
plusieurs procès plusieurs plaintes du
moins qui sont déjà déposées contre les
responsables politiques au niveau
gouvernemental
ceux là veulent tout faire pour ne pas
être responsable ils sont responsables
de la mauvaise gestion de la crise
sanitaire ils sont responsables avec ce
ce grand confinement de la crise
économique dans laquelle nous sommes
c'est pas les seuls bien sûr c'est au
niveau mondial mais faut voir le niveau
à laquelle se retrouvent l'économie
française est aujourd'hui donc que
l'idée de d'aider des gens qui l'ont mis
un finalement en difficulté je crois que
on a un conseil scientifique qui a donné
tous les conseils qu'il fallait on a des
professionnels de médecine qui savent
très bien comment faire et qui demande
des moyens ça veut dire quoi
des gens supplémentaire des lits
supplémentaires jamais cela n'ont été
entendus
pour ce qui est de l'éducation c'est
pareil les professeurs demandent de
dédoubler les classes davantage de
professeurs on a des soi-disant des
milliards qui vont venir de l'union
européenne avec ce plan de relance
plutôt que de l'utiliser à embaucher
finalement des personnels pour aider là
où c'est nécessaire dans le dans les
temps qui viennent
et bien non on va aider les banques à ne
pas faire faillite on va aider les
grandes entreprises à faire des plans
sociaux
on va un peu donné aux tpe et pme qui
elles vont avoir beaucoup de mal c'est
elles qui font l'emploi en europe et en
france je le rappelle donc tout est fait
à l'envers par ces technocrates parce
qu'ils décident de paris parce qu'ils se
refusent à finalement écouté et à
reconnaître leurs erreurs
enfin c'était incroyable d'entendre à
nouveau si bête ndiaye
devant la commission denquête et pour
dire que abbaoui comme d'habitude c'est
la faute des français qui n'y
comprennent rien non les français en ont
marre d'entendre ça en ont marre d'être
pris pour des idiots ils ne sont pas
idiots et je crois que ça va très mal se
passer dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent si le gouvernement ne change
pas de stratégie par rapport à la
gestion de cette crise merci en tout cas
à tous les trois d'avoir répondu à nos
questions n'a bien entendu à vos
interrogations votre incompréhension
parfois votre colère également merci à
vous avec six poulains je rappelle que
vous êtes éditorialistes merci stéphane
ravier président du groupe rassemblement
national au conseil municipal de
marseille et merci à vous et christophe
prudhomme porte parole de l'association
des médecins urgentistes de france et
dans quelques instants nous parlons de
la biélorussie l'union européenne ne
reconnaît pas la légitimité d'alexandre
loukachenko comme président alors qu'il
a prêté serment hier et puis direction
new york et l'assemblée générale de
l'onu
préoccupé par la situation socio
politique en côte d'ivoire
[Musique]
la france n'est pas le seul pays qui a
eu des colonies dans le monde mais c'est
le seul qui refuse d'avancer qu'ils
refusent de s'adapter à l'air du temps
d'accepter un partenariat gagnant
gagnant avec ses anciennes colonies et
je constate aussi que c'est le seul pays
dont aucune des colonies n'a jamais été
développé comment faire en fait pour
établir cette relation gagnant gagnant
c'est pour nous africains de porter à la
tête de nos états des gens qui sont
animés par la recherche de l'intérêt de
leur population
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous s'il arrive
quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pour des tâches
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins ou
du bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que des chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme
c'est quoi le taux de fiabilité du
projet ne serait ce qu'au business et on
oscille entre 92 et 98 points 5 % elle
fonctionne bien ça permet un d'être
rapide d'être non invasif et puis
d'avoir le résultat de façon instantanée
avec un coût qui est quand même bien
moindre plus que sur les coûts actuels
du pcr on va pas sauver l'humanité
souffrent pour révolutionner les choses
avec le travail qu'on fait aux peut-être
faire en sorte ofas appel à savoir faire
savoir faire médical aussi dans un
domaine un peu différent que celui de
l'animal mais après tout l'homme c'est
un animal peu plus tôt
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt francs si
vous nous rejoignez il est 20h30 heure
française
l'assemblée générale de l'onu se
poursuit donc toujours et toujours de
manière virtuelle par visioconférence à
cause du coc vide 19 parmi les discours
de ce jeudi celui de fayez elle
s'arrache c'est le chef du gouvernement
d'union nationale en libye le seul
reconnu par la communauté internationale
et annoncé sa démission d'ailleurs son
pays est en guerre en proie aux
rivalités internes est plongé dans une
crise sans précédent depuis la chute de
mouammar kadhafi
des pourparlers sont en cours est loin
d'être les premiers les précisions avec
françois xavier lambert c'est un pays
qui compte particulièrement sur l'aide
de l'onu pour sortir du chaos après neuf
ans de guerre et de divisions politiques
la libye semble avoir retrouvé un
semblant de stabilité malgré un état
faible et de multiples confrontations
armées face aux nations unies le premier
ministre libyen va à nouveau sollicité
le soutien de l'organisation au
gouvernement d'union nationale le g n a
qu il dirige depuis décembre 2015
fayez al sa rage possède à son crédit
quelques réussites
il est notamment parvenu à obtenir le
ralliement des autorités économiques et
politiques de la capitale tripoli
il peut aussi se targuer d'avoir
notamment renforcer l'armée qui a obtenu
des victoires contre le groupe etat
islamique et les forces du maréchal
haftar l'autre homme fort du pays qui
contrôlent l'est du territoire
mais sa volonté de rassembler n'a pas
permis de surmonter tous les obstacles
fayez al sa rage n'a ainsi pas réussi à
convaincre le parlement exilé dans l'est
du pays à tobrouk est qui soutient son
grand rival la personnalité d'elle sa
rage ne fait également pas consensus au
sein de plusieurs pays arabes qui ont
choisi de soutenir le maréchal haftar
dans ce contexte et pour permettre
pouvoir libyen de trouver un nouveau
souffle
fayez al sa rage a fait part de son
intention de démissionner fin octobre
mais la démo nasa va parler des demis
j'annonce à tous le désir sincère de
remettre mes fonctions à la prochaine
administration au plus tard à la fin du
mois d'octobre prochain
j'espère que le premier thé de
négociations aura alors achevé ses
travaux et choisi un nouveau conseil
présidentiel ainsi jeudi malgré le
départ annoncé de celui qu'elle soutient
l'onu a déjà pris des initiatives pour
poursuivre la lente reconstruction
libyenne
la mission des nations unies dans le
pays a été prolongée sur le plan
politique
l'onu est également en train de
reprendre la main notamment sur les
négociations
les rivaux libyens ont repris des
pourparlers en suisse et à bouznika au
maroc pour trouver une solution
politique à leur différend mais en
attendant une issue diplomatique
la colère de la population se fait
entendre les manifestations se
multiplient dans l'est et à l'ouest
contre l'élite politique et la
détérioration des conditions de vie
notamment les longues coupures
d'électricité
le chemin de la reconstruction s'annonce
donc toujours complexe en libye les deux
camps rivaux ont pourtant affiché leur
bonne volonté lors de leur dernière
rencontre ils ont convenu d'organiser
des élections présidentielle et
parlementaires d'ici à 18 mois
en attendant un gouvernement d'unité
représentatifs devrait être mise en
place
et parmi les autres intervenants
aujourd'hui à l'assemblée générale des
nations unies le président ivoirien
alassane ouattara notamment déploré le
soutien insuffisant des grandes
économies à l'afrique dans la lutte
contre la pandémie
il a également assuré que la prochaine
présidentielle dans son pays se
déroulerait de manière apaisée pourtant
une large partie de la classe politique
s'oppose à une troisième candidature
d'alassane ouattara tout de suite le
point sépare visioconférence que le
président ivoirien prend la parole
devant l'assemblée générale des nations
unies alors que se profile la
présidentielle fixée au 31 octobre
prochain alassane ouattara adopte un ton
rassurant et assure que le processus
démocratique se poursuit peuple ivoirien
va élire le 31 octobre guen il d'un sens
prochain président de la république un
dp
de la crise sanitaire liée à la codi 19
toutes les dispositions sont prises pour
que cette les siens soient apaisées et
transparentes
à l'image ne sommes 2015 malgré cette
apparente sérénité la situation
politique en côte d'ivoire reste tendue
en cause la décision du conseil
constitutionnel de valider la
candidature d'alassane ouattara un
troisième mandat présidentiel tout en
rejetant celle de ses opposants et
notamment celle de son principal rival
l'ex premier ministre guillaume soro
la juridiction suprême a également
refusé 39 autres des 44 candidatures
présentées pour le scrutin dont celle de
l'ex président ivoirien laurent gbagbo
qui compte encore de nombreux partisans
face à ce qu'ils considèrent comme une
manoeuvre du pouvoir
un autre ancien président ivoirien henri
konan-bédié à lui appelé à la
désobéissance civile
en tenant ce discours
henri konan-bédié a attiré à ses côtés
de nombreux partis d'opposition qui
refusent eux aussi la nouvelle
candidature d'alassane ouattara la
constitution ivoirienne limite en effet
le nombre de mandats présidentiels à
deux mais selon la juridiction suprême
l'entrée en vigueur d'une nouvelle
constitution en 2016 a remis les
compteurs à zéro
ces tensions grandissantes dans le pays
font planer la menace d'une nouvelle
crise post électorale meurtrière
semblable à celle de 2010 près de 3000
personnes avaient perdu la vie lors des
affrontements qui ont suivi le refus de
laurent gbagbo de reconnaître la
victoire revendiquée par son opposant
d'alors alassane ouattara et pour en
parler nous sommes avec alafé wakili
journaliste directeur général du
quotidien ivoirien l'intelligent
d'abidjan
alafé wakili merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors avant de
revenir sur la situation dans le pays
peut être un mot sur la demande du
président ivoirien il apprenait ce jeudi
auprès des nations unies
le recours aux droits de tirage spéciaux
c'est une sorte de monnaie créée par le
fmi pour aider les pays africains à
faire face à l'impact économique de
l'épidémie de kobe de 19
la situation économique est plus que
préoccupante aujourd'hui sur le
continent
oui elle est préoccupante mais on ne
pourrait pas dit qu'elle est plus que
préoccupante elle à l'image de la
situation dans plusieurs pays au monde
évaluation de la dette a été préconisé
des visas hâtive continue comme celle de
droits de tirage spéciaux maintenant la
question aussi c'est la prêtrise si on a
trop de dette qui on en fait trop si
lorsque la crise finira il faudra
toujours bien payé
et puis subit donc côté des solutions
alors revenons à la situation en côte
d'ivoire détention avant les élections
qui se profilent
le conseil constitutionnel a validé la
candidature d'alassane ouattara mais pas
celle de guillaume soro ou de laurent
gbagbo pour quelles raisons guillaume
soro et laurent gbagbo ils ont été
condamnés par la justice ivoirienne ces
îles sont fièrement les couleurs est
reproché et cette condamnation a fait
qu' ils ne sont pas sur la liste
électorale or on être éligible on pourra
être candidat il faut être électrique
ont figuré sur la liste électorale
c'est la principale raison qui est leur
a été opposé
ils ont entre et d'eric ou qui n'ont pas
prospéré d'encore ils ne sont pas sur la
liste électorale ne sont pas électeur et
le conseil constitutionnel a indiqué
qu'il n'était pas possible tu es le soir
éligibles parce que c'est reçu sa
demande dans le pays par le peuple
ivoirien
quelles sont les réactions bon les
réactions bien entendu sont actuellement
négative dans les différents
états-majors d'aller différents partis
politiques
il faut dire ici que comme tout et
partout dans le monde y difficile de
déterminer si c'était peut être le petit
moyen en tant qu une seule entité une
s'il voit actuellement mais toujours est
il qu'il ya une opposition qui est
unanime malgré ses contradictions elle
parvient à se rassembler pour dénoncer
en particulier peut-être ce retrait des
candidatures est aussi l'accueil natif
du privé alassane ouattara
mais ça participe au des divisions ici
qu'il ya dans le pays
il n'est pas possible de donner une idée
de d'une opinion générale ou
majoritaires en des eaux des élections
qui arrivent
voilà c'est tellement on vous parlait
d'une opposition soudée une opposition
qui considère la candidature d'alassane
ouattara comme illégal car il a déjà
effectué deux mandats c'est le maximum
mais pour le conseil constitutionnel les
compteurs retombe à zéro
au vu de la constitution 2016 c'est
réellement le cas maintenant chacun a
une opinion personnelle sur la question
en fonction de ses préoccupations pour
centrer convictions mais du point de vue
du droit n a été trouvée mais c'est que
je veux éviter c'est que même ceux qui
contestent la quelle date du présent
reconnaît sa des niveaux que c'est un
d'activités possibles en admettant que
s'il y avait une élection anticipée
c'est à dire il a fait un premier mandat
2010 2015
le second mandat et en 2015 et puis la
nouvelle concession 2016 en
reconnaissant que s'il y avait une
élection anticipée en 2016 2017 2018 en
tout cas avant le 31 octobre 2020
le conte aurait été niée à 0 n'est ce
pas une manière de dire que oui le
contact est conçu de commis à 0,6 la
possibilité d'une élection anticipée
pour mettre nos comptes à zéro et ne pas
perdre et d'être rigide sur le fait de
10 à 10 ans fait des érections 2 et
lisibilité 2 tandis battu importe qu'il
ait une élection anticipée ou pas le
compteur ne peut pas être à zéro mais il
sait ne verrait pas possible d'entrer
dans cette rigidité absolue si une
élection anticipée aurait pu annuler
l'argumenter je pense que yves est
possible sauf disposition expresse dans
la nouvelle constitution est nativement
au présent l'exercice de permettre cet
ami dati point de vue de légal d'autant
plus que c'est la même chose en guinée
c'est la même chose dans d'autres pays
qui ont lu ce type de situation
alors les partis d'opposition on le
disait unis contre la candidature de
ouattara sur place qu est ce que vous
sentez est ce qu'on peut craindre que la
russe mobilisent et est-ce qu'on peut
assister à des nouvelles violences selon
vous oui c'est possible qu'on pèse plus
personne ne peut déterminer ce qu'il
peut se passer mais ce qu'il faut noter
c'est que il ya la tension wii qui monte
mais aussi à une détermination partagée
à tous les niveaux l'opposition est vent
debout mais on sent de part et d'autre
de la fiabilité de la colère de
l'énervement ça peut dégénérer comme ici
la responsabilité peut prévaloir et le
sens de la responsabilité pleine et en
navarre emploi ailleurs penser que l est
pour l'instant le cas puisque malgré
l'appel à la désobéissance civile lancé
l'opposition peut-être donner encore des
chances au dialogue avec les
concertations entreprises par les
nations unies où le moment qu'ils
rencontrent les différents acteurs
attendant certainement qu'un rapport
soit fait dans ce contexte là les appels
pour les actions effectives de
désobéissance civile peut être
consistant éventuellement à paralyser le
pays à manifester à a tout bloqué avec
aussi la réponse éventuellement du
gouvernement tout cela n'est pas encore
en jeu on peut donc penser que le
dialogue souterraine qui se passe à
travers l'onu et d'autres organisations
amené à baisser la tension
comme si ça peut jouer et puis la
conscience en coin dans koh jusqu'au 31
12 octobre mais on espère que ce sera
l'aspect positif qui va prévaloir de
part et d'autre merci alafé wakili pour
votre éclairage je rappelle que vous
êtes journaliste et directeur général du
quotidien ivoirien l'intelligent
d'abidjan est tout de suite direction la
biélorussie alexandre loukachenko a
prêté serment hier pour un sixième
mandat mais l'union européenne a
réaffirmé sa position par la voix de
jose
borel le chef de la diplomatie
européenne il a fait savoir que l'union
européenne refusait toujours de
reconnaître alexandre loukachenko comme
président du pays des sanctions à
l'encontre de l'homme au pouvoir depuis
26 ans sont toujours à l'étude
et pour en parler nous sommes avec jean
de gliniasty est directeur de recherche
à l'institut de relations
internationales et stratégiques et
ancien ambassadeur de russie et auteur
de géopolitique de la russie aux
éditions eyrolles jean de gliniasty
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france alors en france d'ici où je parle
d'une cérémonie d'investiture en toute
discrétion en catimini d'alexandre
loukachenko
pourtant quand on voit les images on a
le sentiment d'un rendez vous plutôt
officiel est ce que le président
biélorusse a vraiment souhaité une
investiture en catimini seront écoutés
oui il me semble que l'une institue une
investiture de de ce genre normalement
c'est une grande fête tout le monde est
sur la place on agite des drapeaux
c'est un événement national là
manifestement il a fait ça un peu à la
sauvette
la presse du monde entier l'asnl a
remarqué y compris d'ailleurs la presse
russe
et c'est normal d'ailleurs en cas de
crise de ce genre que ça se passe comme
ça à sa place
sur la passe et autres comment alors
justement cette intronisation en
catimini discrète est ce qu elle est
nature à amplifier la contestation dans
le pays selon vous plutôt à amplifier
qu'autre chose
quand quand nous avons le l'union
européenne qui ne reconnaît pas la
légitimité du nouveau président en fait
ça mais de ça ajoute de l'eau au moulin
de ceux qui y compris d'ailleurs un
moment lukashenko mais il a un peu
oublié ce qu'il a dit lui-même qui
prévoit un changement de constitution de
nouvelles élections et donc dé facto un
nouveau gouvernement
donc en fait cet appel au changement
s'exprime de façon très différente par
des voies différentes et parfois pas
forcément du même avis mais tant du côté
de la russie que du côté de l'europe que
du côté de loukachenko dans ses
déclarations il ya quinze jours
tout le monde reconnaît qu'il faut un
changement de régime un changement de
constitution c'est un changement de
régime alors l'union européenne et les
etats unis on le disait on ne
reconnaissent pas lukashenko comme
président il y à des sanctions qui sont
à l'étude
le chef d'état biélorusse aujourd'hui
lui craint davantage des sanctions de la
part de l'union européenne où il craint
davantage la contestation de la rue
selon vous les sanctions de l'union
européenne il en a déjà eu
puisque à chaque élection le même
scénario se reproduit à peu près cette
fois ci il est beaucoup plus grave que
la dernière fois et donc l'union
européenne prend des sanctions et les
dernières sanctions ont été levées quand
donc en 2016 et il en resterait encore
quelques-unes je crois mais donc l union
européenne la pente des sanctions le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est tout cas
celle qu on y est habitué à supposer que
l'union européenne les prennent puisque
comme on le sait ya certains états qui
s'y opposent dont chypre
donc ce qu'il craint surtout c'est la
déstabilisation de la rue alors
justement vous l'évoquez à l'instant il
reste que l'unanimité des états membres
de l'union européenne
soit requise et tous ne sont pas
d'accord
quels sont les divergences sur la
question alors le point essentiel mais
il y en a d'autres
c'est que chypre estime que en gros il
ya deux poids deux mesures c'est à dire
qu'on prend des sanctions contre la
biélorussie mais on n'en prend pas
contre la turquie qui est un peu un
sujet tabou et qui enfreint les autres
victoria le chypriote et grecque
donc ça c'est un premier point et puis
si je comprends bien mais ça mérite
d'être confirmée il ya des états qui se
cache derrière chypre
parce que par exemple on dit que la
suède aura bientôt le la présidence de
l'osce c est que l'eau est ce que
pourrait jouer un rôle de médiatrice
envoyer une mission et que donc la suède
serait intéressé à avoir ce rôle
alors du côté de la russie
comment est ce qu'on regarde ce dossier
qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre maintenant
la russie la situation est extrêmement
embarrassantes
d'abord il est de notoriété publique que
les relations entre lukashenko et
poutine sont mauvaises depuis très
longtemps la biélorussie fait un peu
chantée la russie essayant d'obtenir des
avantages pétrolier financiers
commerciaux en échange de son soutien à
à la russie et surtout à la construction
d'une union eurasiatique
donc il ya de l'agacement il y avait de
l'agacement il y en a encore mais la
russie est bien obligé de constater que
la biélorussie a été un des états
fondateurs de toutes les instances que
la russie a construite pour essayer de
garder une zone d' influence dans la
région dans les anciennes républiques de
l'urss c'est à dire l'organisation du
traité de sécurité collective ou bien le
razia tic dont on en parlait à l'instant
est donc fondamentalement la biélorussie
reste un allié
j'allais dire fondamental de la russie
donc laissé déstabiliser la
la biélorussie ça n'est pas possible
mais en même temps les russes
comprennent bien aussi que quand on a
tout ce monde là dans la rue et que en
général ce sont des jeunes et c'est
l'avenir du pays et notamment la classe
moyenne ceux qui sont employés dans les
industries techniques et technologiques
et et donc il ya quand même une large
majorité du pays qui veulent le départ
de loukachenko et c'est intéressant de
voir d'ailleurs que parmi les candidats
qui voulait son départ vous avez à la
fois des pro russe des pro-occidentaux
des blogueurs enfin si vous prenez les
profils de baricco de cette kahlo 2-9
callas etc
vous avez en gros 1 j'ai une photo de la
quasi totalité de la population
biélorusse donc ça là les autorités
russes ne peuvent pas ne pas le
remarquer le prendre en compte
d'où les propositions qu'on a
semble-t-il plus ou moins suggéré à
moscou à loukachenko
c'est à dire de d'opérer en douceur un
changement de régime pour intégrer une
partie de cette jeunesse et ce
changement de régime c'est cette fameuse
proposition de nouvelle constitution et
de nouvelles élections
merci beaucoup jean de gliniasty pour
votre décryptage rappelle que vous êtes
directeur de recherche à l'institut de
relations internationales et
stratégiques
ancien ambassadeur de russie et auteur
de géopolitique de la russie aux
éditions eyrolles et rester avec nous
sur rt france dans quelques instants
nous reviendrons sur les mesures
restrictives annoncé par olivier véran
la guadeloupe placées en zones d'alert
maximale sur l'île est les nouveaux cas
augmente de façon inquiétante
on craint une saturation des services de
réanimation puis nous parlerons de la
mobilisation des magistrats ce jeudi
dans toute la france pour protester
contre les agissements du garde des
sceaux
eric dupond moretti a tout de suite sur
rtl france
[Musique]
le troisième mandat d'alassane ouattara
ce n'était pas prévu amadou gon
coulibaly était le candidat choisi à
l'unanimité dont des cadres du rhdp
malheureusement lui jugé amadou gon
coulibaly est décédé pourquoi
aujourd'hui le président et candidat à
sa propre succession
nous estimons que l'opposant ouattara
est celui qui a le leadership nécessaire
pour faire face ont pu fiction posent à
nous tant au niveau interne ou externe
un climat particulier en ce moment en
côte d'ivoire des violences sous
prétexte d'une manifestation et
d'expression de droit démocratique
on incite à la haine on estime m est-ce
que sincèrement vous êtes certains que
le scrutin du 31 octobre sera maintenu à
la date prévue
mais il n'y a pas de raison que ce
scrutin ne soit pas maintenu
certains disent que nous ne sommes pas
une chaîne française
d'autres affirment même que nous ne
sommes pas journalistes mais vous
[Musique]
savez-vous vraiment qui nous sommes
les valeurs que nous défendons la
liberté
la liberté d'expression et d'opinion
nous défendons l'égalité l'égalité des
chances pour tous
[Musique]
nous sommes une équipe
nous sommes cette diversité qui fait la
france
et nous en sommes fiers
[Musique]
et si vous veniez voir par vous même
vous parlez de résilience comment est-ce
qu'on pourrait le définir
c'est après un traumatisme qu'est ce
qu'on sait combien on reste traumatisée
bien on cherche en soi et autour de
soins quels sont les facteurs qui vont
permettre de reprendre un nouveau
développement et là on parle de
résilience la catastrophe économique
dont on parle
elle est liée directement au confinement
c'est à dire à la mise en coma
artificiel de l'économie catastrophe ça
veut dire à côté
cata strophe là il ya un tournant mais
on recevait à vivre mais dans une autre
direction c'est la première fois dans
l'histoire de l'humanité que pour sauver
des vies humaines en ruines
la moitié de la planète jamais on a fait
ça jamais plaint d'une décision
invraisemblable pour vos ça dépend
quelle valeur on attribuait la mort la
vie humaine
si on considère que la vie humaine est
plus précieuse que l'économie revient
fait mais si on considère que maintenant
il va y avoir des catastrophes humaines
individuelles avec cette décision
alors je sais pas c'est un débat moral
des baltique
[Musique]
quelle reprise économique pour l'après
coded 19
à quoi peut-on s'attendre on a été dans
l'oeil du cyclone cet été en fait ça
fait à peu près trente ans que la
croissance structurelle en france baisse
donc elle va continuer à être au mieux
médiocre et au pire catastrophique les
prévisions que peuvent faire le fmi ou
la deutsche bank a cédé prévisions ou
doigt mouillé ça n'a pas grande valeur
si l'état était capable de relancer
l'économie la france est le pays plus
développés du monde beaucoup de pays
était déjà en récession donc le coville
n'a été qu'un catalyseur en fait de ce
qui s'est passé pour une économie
croatie il faut que ceux qui prennent
des risques gagne plus d'argent que ce
qui entraîne pas parler de croissance
car on prend toutes les mesures qu'il
faut pour que les entrepreneurs ne gagne
pas d'argent
j'ai un peu pas bien sérieux
entre 800 et 1000 tonnes de fuel se sont
déversés dans les eaux turquoises
mauricienne ce qu'il faudrait étendre l
enquête aux autorités portuaires voir
plus haut
nous devrons a annoncé une enquête une
fois nous devons maintenant établir la
chaîne de responsabilités nationales
il faut savoir que la partie arrière du
bateau contient encore environ 50 à 100
tonnes de fioul
donc ça pourrait aussi actuellement se
fracasser et causé un deuxième
déversement de pétrole plus ça arrive
après les convives 19 ans secteur
hôtelier et touristique est à genoux
l'ensemble des impacts de la catastrophe
sur l'environnement marin mais aussi sur
les populations niveau de la santé vont
se faire ressentir pendant des décennies
il faut s'attendre aujourd'hui à maurice
aussi un désastre sanitaire
il est catastrophe on a vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pessimiste que
c'est
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous
petits échos positifs n'a jamais été
obligé de dire la vie les idées
courageuse des mots qui comptent la
haine en soi vient des guignols
aujourd'hui on est une gauche qui
extrait tous les témoins de notre époque
sont dans la grande interview
écoutez moi tout le monde si vous faites
trop de bruit je vais vous renvoyer dans
la salle de classe entendu certaines
personnes n'aiment pas le cirque
nous devons éveiller l'intérêt pour le
cirque chez les adultes et les enfants
pour les inciter à venir et à apprendre
[Musique]
et bien leur fait d'une main et
rattraper avec l'autre
[Musique]
le joue à quoi joue est important pour
un an
il ya eu un bombardement récemment tout
le monde a été tuée femmes vieillards et
enfants
tout a été détruit il ya un monde à
l'extérieur
il en existe un autre ici à l'intérieur
de ses murs
[Musique]
14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président tron va décider de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en bougeant par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes ne les avons nous pas
pousser dans les bras d'un partenaire
qui va en profiter pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature du pdc y votre parti reste
crédible
à partir du moment où le plaisir et
colombier revire la course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement on peut
réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifestes
et dénigrement d'exprimer leurs opinions
en toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de nous allons
retrouver le pouvoir gagner ces
élections et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'allons pas les
poursuivre pour les fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation vraie d ivoire
[Musique]
bonsoir et merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'information il
est 21h heure de paris tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité de ce jeudi 24
septembre 2020 l'union européenne
appelle les états membres à durcir les
mesures face au co l'idée c'est chose
faite en france mais les nouvelles
restrictions annoncées hier par olivier
véran provoque incompréhension et colère
surtout dans la région de marseille
placée en alerte maximale
tout comme la guadeloupe où 37 personnel
soignant militaires sont envoyés sur
place en renfort une vague mais deux
rébellions cette fois celle des
magistrats mobilisés cet après midi à
l'appel de deux syndicats devant les
tribunaux de france en cause eric
dupond-moretti accusé de vouloir
affaiblir l'autorité judiciaire
il est notamment demandé au garde des
sceaux de venir constater les
difficultés dans lesquelles sont les
magistrats elle les greffiers et les
avocats
[Musique]
le chef de la diplomatie iranienne
mohammed javad sari fait à moscou où il
a rencontré son homologue russe sergueï
lavrov
au centre des discussions les récentes
sanctions américaines à l'encontre de
téhéran est la syrie mais aussi les
pressions sur le projet north stream
[Musique]
une cyber attaque autour de julian
assange qui interroge la pétition
hashtag free assange de reporters sans
frontières et certaines pages du site
internet de l'organisation ont subi une
attaque en ligne l'organisation reste
déterminé à obtenir la libération du
fondateur de wikileaks et à empêcher son
extradition vers les etats-unis son
procès se tient à londres depuis le 7
septembre
[Musique]
sans atteindre le niveau de mars dernier
plusieurs indicateurs montrent que
l'épidémie est reparti à la hausse plus
de 16 mille cas ces dernières 24 heures
et 52 décès le gouvernement a donc durci
le ton avec de nouvelles mesures
restrictives annoncé par olivier ferrand
à la nouvelle cartographie de l'épidémie
montre que le pays n'est pas logé à la
même enseigne selon les zones
paris passe en zone d' alerte renforcée
tout comme lille ou bordeaux est les
rassemblements de plus de dix personnes
seront interdits dans les espaces
publics les bars et restaurants devront
fermer à 22h
dès lundi et plus grave les zones
placées en alerte maximale elles sont au
nombre de deux la métropole d'aix
marseille et la guadeloupe
sur place la fermeture des bars et
restaurants est totale et cela rentre en
vigueur dès samedi
une mesure que beaucoup ne comprennent
pas regardé je pense que les mesures
sont un peu forte pour pour les
restaurateurs et pour toute l'économie
de la guadeloupe
déjà que c'était dur de se remettre du
dernier compte innovants et à presque
personne
normalement il ya beaucoup de monde ça
fait chuter énormément la clientèle donc
on se demande si on va pouvoir rester
ouvert au moins en vente à emporter
mais en termes des dons on a tous
souscrit à des pg e mais ce sont des
crédits qu'il va falloir rembourser on
ne sait pas avec quel argent pour mes
autres sociétés parce que c'est une
catastrophe
et donc aujourd'hui non on est on
on reporte de charges alors qu'on aurait
tous souhaité une annulation le il faut
vous faut mettre plus d'être en place
pour pour les restaurateurs parce que
sinon ça va être une désolation vous
allez voir le nombre de sociétés qui
vont fermer
le nombre d'employés qui vont se
retrouver au chômage ça va être une
catastrophe
fermez les restaurants fermés les
restaurants pour moi ce n'est pas une
mesure que les restaurants je pense
qu'il est vraiment fallu pour confiner
pendant quinze jours et au moins pour
limiter la circulation douce ou pas
c'est un couvre feu
je pense qu'il faut vraiment tout
reconfigurer parce que c'est ridicule
une partie des littoraux une partie bar
une partie c'est d'autre chose
donc les gens ne faut pas vraiment
comprendre puisque les gens les médecins
les professionnels n 10 a aujourd'hui la
l'admin dit autre chose
par exemple les masques regarder au
début c'était pas obligatoire apprécié
était obligatoire après c'était
recommandé
on ne sait plus où donner de la tête
avec ça donc on a subi au final mans et
je ne sais pas si jusqu'à quel point on
va se sentir
et pour revenir sur la situation en
guadeloupe nous sommes avec christine
christelle health infirmières libérales
sur place christelle hans merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
en métropole notamment à marseille la
fermeture des bars et des restaurants a
suscité beaucoup de colère c'est la même
chose en guadeloupe où c'est un peu plus
mes yeux mesurer non c'est la même chose
là à la mesure est pas vraiment
comprises
elle est pas facilement accepté et c'est
vrai que on a déjà beaucoup souffert
lors de beurre du confinement total
et là c'est vrai que c'est pas évident
alors pour la fermière que vous êtes
elles sont quand même nécessaire face à
la situation sanitaire ces mesures selon
vous ou alors il aurait peut-être fallu
en prendre d'autres
je pense qu'elles soient effectivement
nécessaire elle devrait être mieux
expliquer mieux comprise parce qu'en
fait ici les rassemblements
dans la famille etc ce tracé c'est
vraiment dans les moeurs locaux et les
gens beaucoup beaucoup de mal à
comprendre qu'il ne faut pas voilà qu'il
est distanciation sociale les gestes
barrière même si beaucoup les respecte
en ville dans les magasins on les voit
mais dans la sphère privée ça ne suffit
pas les bars les restaurants ils ont
pris des mesures face à la situation
sanitaire gel hydroalcoolique à la
sortie des débats ou encore le port du
masque quand on se déplace à l'intérieur
des établissements c'est bien respecter
ou pas sur l'île en grande majorité oui
c'est respecter en grande majorité sait
respecter
après il ya toujours des petits bars des
petits lolo ou non mais bien sûr mais
c'est vrai que les grandes relais
grandes enseignes les grands restaurants
et alors concernant la situation
notamment celle des soignants quelle est
elle
aujourd'hui on évoque des soignants
presque en burn out est ce que vous
confirmez
alors les soigneurs à l'hôpital je pense
qu'effectivement sont vraiment à bout de
souffle mais nous en libéral on est
aussi à bout de souffle alors c'est vrai
que l'on nous sollicite pour aller
travailler renforcer l'hôpital mais on a
nos patients à domicile et nous on fait
tout notre possible justement pour ne
pas les envoyer à l'hôpital dont on ne
pas les contaminer pour les garder en
meilleure santé possible et on nous
demande en plus d'aller de l'hôpital au
risque de se contaminer nous mêmes et
donc après de contaminer nos patients et
c'est quelque chose qui pour nous est
extrêmement difficile on ne peut pas on
a déjà des journées de travail qui sont
extrêmement lourdes aller en plus de
lait du renfort à l'hôpital
c'est très difficile et pourtant on sait
l'hôpital complètement surchargé
débordés de travail de vraiment dans des
conditions très très difficile william
et harry oui en libéral pardonnez moi je
vous ai coupé en libéral c'est aussi
très utile pour nous parce que nous on
est sur le pont tous les jours de très
très tôt le matin jusque très tard le
soir
et on a non seulement notre patient
accompagné mon à toute la famille à
éduquer toute la famille a un coût de
chez en fait parce que c'est vraiment du
coaching au quotidien et voilà avec avec
je vous dis des moeurs locaux qui sont
totalement à l'opposé de ce qu'on leur
demande de faire
alors le déploiement des renforts
militaires du service de santé des
armées est prévue est ce que c'est déjà
un soulagement oui ça va être vraiment
une grande aide
ça va être vraiment une grande aide la
réserve militaire la réserve civile va
vraiment soulager beaucoup les équipes
qui vont les équipes sur place parce
qu'elles sont vraiment épuisée en termes
de moyens sur place en termes
d'équipement en termes de masse qu
est-ce que vous avez le stock
suffisamment nécessaire vous par exemple
alors nous en fait en libéral on a eu le
stock de masques de l'état saraka
semaine prochaine on a plus de dotations
de l'état officiellement la semaine
prochaine
donc on a reçu déjà un message et une
quinzaine de jours je crois où nous
demandait de faire des stocks d'acheter
du matériel mais le matériel ici à a été
multiplié par je sais pas signé on
achète nos gants on achète nos surblouse
on achète nos tenues il ya collé le
cinematic nous vous parler du prix de
ddd du matériel qui a fortement augmenté
ces derniers mois
oui ça a été j'ai plié parfois par dix
d'un 36 impressionnant comment est ce
que vous envisagez les prochaines
semaines au vu de la situation sur place
c'est difficile parce qu en fait autant
lors de la première vague alors qu'on
avait moins de cas et moins de moins
deux morts - dont les services étaient
moins surchargé tout le monde a pris la
mesure beaucoup plus au sérieux que je
trouve maintenant où effectivement ça
fait des mois qu'on droit ça fait
plusieurs semaines en tout cas qu'on
doit porter le masque on nous parle de
distanciation social limite j'aurais
tendance à dire c'est presque banalisés
maintenant et alors qu'il faudrait qu'on
multiplie nos mots nos précautions
maintenant parce que les cas sont
beaucoup plus importants et c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs que les cas se multiplient
parce que les gens ont lâché
lâcher prise dans ce contexte vous nous
en parler un petit peu tout à l'heure
mais votre activité en plein coli elle
ressemble à quoi aujourd'hui
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup d'éducation
beaucoup de prévention en plus parce que
tous les patients sont des patients bien
évidemment âgées fragiles on a beaucoup
de diabète on a beaucoup de dialyse et
on a beaucoup donc de patients qui qui
ont des pathologies associées qui sont
des facteurs de comorbidité qu'ils sont
majeurs et on doit le patient lui même
nous on va réussir à gérer on a réussi à
expliquer en ballerines j'ai réussi à
comprendre toutes les précautions
mais la famille autour par contre ils
comprennent pas ils comprennent pas le
port du masque qui vont pas porter le
masque à côté de leurs patients et de
leurs proches ils vont pas les enfants
sont là la vie ici c'est vraiment une
vie en communauté familiale très très
très serré et leur faire comprendre les
gestes barrière le lavage des mains
c'est très gentil mais quand on a de
l'eau voilà même nous à domicile
au niveau des soins d'hygiène et des
toilettes quand on a de l'eau quand on
n'a pas d'eau urbains on se débrouille
avec avec les moyens du bord avec une
cuvette avec des bouteilles dans les
écoles c'est pareil dans les écoles ça a
été catastrophique au niveau des
fermetures de dix cours d'eau
merci beaucoup crient style and d'avoir
partagé votre témoignage rappelle que
vous êtes infirmières libérales en
guadeloupe et c'est dans ce contexte de
hausse de l'épidémie que la commission
d' enquête du sénat sur la gestion de la
crise sanitaire auditionné ce matin au
lycée vers en masque test chiffres le
ministre de la santé s'est expliqué les
détails avec leila sarah olivier véran à
l'aise loin d'être tondus devant la
commission d' enquête du sénat pour la
gestion de l'épidémie de covile 19
il dénonce les difficultés d'un pays
hyper normes et ce qui peut être perçu
comme des problèmes de latence ne serait
pas de son ressort
on fait gaffe à tous quand des masques
arrivent de chine même si vous en
manquez sur le territoire où les
distribuer passer la douane n'a pas
vérifié que les masques sont conformes
et efficace et efficient entre le moment
où vous décidez de quelque chose et le
moment où la chose est opérationnel
efficace
ça prend des jours nous avons un système
particulièrement normatif en france mais
il est signé des décrets d arrêter à
tour de bras pour simplifier les choses
mais que voulez vous il ya des choses
prennent du temps je croyais moi je le
regrette au mans comme agnès buzyn avant
lui olivier vers ans se défend de tout
incompétence la france aurait même eu un
temps d'avancé mettant rendu moi même
quelques jours après ma nomination à
rome pour rencontrer des ministres de la
santé et deux semaines après ma
nomination à bruxelles pour discuter
avec l'ensemble de mes homologues
européens dont une majorité importante
se demandaient pourquoi est-ce qu'on
réunisse et en urgence les ministres du
concept de du conseil de l'europe compte
tenu qu'ils n'avaient pas d'épidémie en
europe
je peux vous dire qu'effectivement
niveau d' alerte était important en
france comparé à beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de voisins qui nous entoure
face au rebond de l'épidémie le
gouvernement sert donc la vis
après l'annus de nouvelles restrictions
la veille olivier veyrat a saisi
l'occasion de réaffirmer son autorité
est toujours en france les magistrats
sont en colère contre leur ministre
l'union syndicale des magistrats et le
syndicat de la magistrature se sont
réunis aujourd'hui à 13 heures devant le
tribunal judiciaire de paris
ils protestent contre les prises de
positions du garde des sceaux notamment
l'ouverture d'une enquête à dmitry
administrative contre trois magistrats
du parquet national financier lé
magistrat reproche à eric dupond-moretti
d'affaiblir l'autorité judiciaire et
l'accusent de conflit d'intérêt je vous
propose d'écouter la présidente du
syndicat de la magistrature ainsi que
hugo berne à berne alice députés elle
est fille de la seconde circonscription
nord
des années par les conditions dans
lesquelles travaillent et jugent mal à
l'épaule qui ne sont pas officiellement
sa moins de droits ils ont de moi j'ai
accès à la justice
en plus ça va plus la justice dépôt des
listes parce qu'elles n'arrivent pas à
traiter correctement les affaires alors
que c'est une condition essentielle en
démocratie de pouvoir traiter
correctement des affaires dans
lesquelles les droits des personnes sont
en jeu et donc aujourd'hui les
magistrats en ont assez qu'on nous
explique qu'en fait c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas l'esprit du contradictoire que
les choses vont mal c'est parce qu'ils
n'ont pas l'esprit effectivement du
respect des droits de la défense
non ce sont des lois qui ont été votées
c'est la volonté du législateur d'avoir
modifié en attendant des choses c'est
important pour nous parce que on combat
et vous le savez depuis nos perquisition
mais pas qu'eux aussi pour un mouvement
déjà les jeunes de l'instrumentalisation
politique d'injustice et là on est
parfaitement dans le cas de figure d'une
instrumentalisation politique de la
justice par l'exécutif par le garde des
sceaux eric dupond-moretti pour des
intérêts particuliers les siens d'abord
et on peut aussi supposer que ce soit
pour d'autres qu'aux intérêts et le
ministre de la justice qui s'est exprimé
à ce sujet écoutez c'est l'expression
syndicale
voilà les seuls à s'exprimer moi je suis
un démocrate convaincu les syndicats
disent ce qu'ils ont envie de dire et
moi je dis aussi ce que j'ai envie de
dire et pour en parler nous sommes avec
eux antonin peschard avocat antonin
peschard merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors la colère des
magistrats finalement elle se concentre
surtout sur le parquet national
financiers écoutez moi ce que ce que je
constate c'est que l annonce de la
nomination d'eric dupond-moretti au
ministère de la justice
on a tout de suite une levée de
boucliers biscons à une les syndicats
parlent de déclaration de guerre
on parle donc sur une base sans que le
ministre n'ait rien fait ne rien
annoncer qui est déjà très mauvaise
c'est là où pour ma part je suis surpris
aujourd'hui tous bien se cristalliser
sur la question du parquet national
financiers
je rappelle quand même que
le soir de sa nomination le ministre a
retiré sa plainte pénale
et c'est là où il ya une distinction
très importante à faire siffler les
syndicats de la magistrature font les
dents les syndicats font l'économie
c'est que l' enquête pénale à eric
dupond-moretti n'est plus partie à cette
procédure
en revanche le fait que le ministre
demande une enquête administrative qui
peut effectivement déboucher sur du
disciplinaire fait partie de ses
prérogatives
lorsqu'on a un professionnel qui dont on
suppose qu'il a pu commettre une faute
il est normal que des instances qui sont
prévus pour mener ses enquêtes puissent
le faire je vais faire le parallèle avec
notre profession nous dès lors qu' il ya
des suspicions
nous sommes poursuivis par nos autorités
de poursuite
et ça ça ne sonne chaque pas les
magistrats donc pourquoi sont-ils choqué
du fait que le ministre use de ses
prérogatives pour mener une à une une
enquête administrative je le répète à
laquelle lui-même n'est pas parti alors
offert il ya distinction il y aussi
cette accusation de vous voir à
affaiblir l'autorité judiciaire et est
ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer qu est
ce qu il faut comprendre
j'aimerais bien qu'on m'explique
parce que l'autorité judiciaire connaît
un affaiblissement depuis de nombreuses
années et d'ailleurs on le voit puisque
dans l'ordre protocolaire des ministères
la justice ne fait que descendre
demandant aux mandats donc c'est pas
eric dupond moretti qui est à l'origine
de ça je dirais même que lorsqu'il était
encore à nos confrères et je parle il ya
plusieurs années il a fait honneur à
l'institution judiciaire
en étant premiers défenseurs le premier
dénonciateur de ce qui se passait dans
le procès d'outreau et je pense que la
grogne des magistrats a pour origine
déjà ce procès
à travers lequel effectivement
finalement la colère est ce qu'elle est
pas également alimentée par la
personnalité même d'eric dupond-moretti
et et ses déclarations passées comme
celles sur outreau vous venez d'évoquer
justement absolument absolument c'est
une question personnelle
d'ailleurs c'est pour ça que j'ai
commencé mon propos en rappelant que dès
sa nomination les magistrats en parler
de déclaration de guerre
c'est une question personnelle laissez
le faire son travail est jugé sur ses
actes
s'il est un bon ministre ou pas puisque
jusqu'à preuve du contraire il ya un an
lorsqu'il était avocat
il n'a fait que son travail de défendre
ses clients contre les juridictions et
ça c'est sa liberté d'avocats il a une
liberté de parole et personne ne m'aime
pas lui reprocher est ce qu'aujourd'hui
en tant que ministre il a eu des mots à
l'encontre des magistrats qui peuvent
relever d'une dinde un faux-pas venant
d'un ministre
à mon sens non d'ailleurs on dit qu'il
ya eric dupond-moretti pataca par
titution judiciaire en nommant une
avocate à la tête de le mi6 et c'est
tout le contraire c'est parfaitement
scandaleux effectuer sa a mis le feu aux
poudres là aussi cette nomination d'une
avocate justement pour diriger le m
je pense que le feu le feu aux poudres a
été mis dès sa nomination
c'est à dire que quoi qu'ils fassent on
l'attaquera les magistrats et les
syndicats de magistrats l'attaquerons
voyez quand même dans le milieu les
magistrats comme les inventaires une
progression extrêmement difficile avec
un manque de moyens évident il n'en
demeure pas moins que au delà de ça il
on doit tous avoir un respect vis-à-vis
de nos autorités
je rappelle que le ministe la justice
n'est pas le ministre des magistrats
mais de toutes les professions
judiciaires et juridiques ce qu'on ne le
retrouve pas dans la composition des
cabinets du de la place vendôme
depuis 1958
moi je voudrais soulever une chose un
ancien magistrat procureur de la
république a donné une interview sud ans
dans la presse papier
eric de montgolfier qui explique très
clairement une chose et là je suis
extrêmement surpris que là les
magistrats ne s'offusque pas il vous
explique très clairement que c'est par
la compromission par la soumission au
pouvoir que les magistrats font carrière
et sa natte ça n'a soulevé aucune
critique de la part des magistrats
qu'attendez vous aujourd'hui du ministre
eric dupond-moretti pour conclure alors
il a deux ans pour en mettre en oeuvre
le programme pour lequel emmanuel macron
l'a choisi moi je pense que dans son
programme il ya deux choses extrêmement
importantes sur lesquelles on va devoir
aller au bout voir plus loin que ce
qu'il propose aujourd'hui on a un
problème de communication entre avocats
et magistrats
toutes les tentatives de réconciliation
ont échoué je pense qu'il faut aller
beaucoup plus loin en demandant en
réformant l'accès à la magistrature sur
un modèle qui se rapproche encore plus
du modèle anglo saxon où tout le monde a
la même formation et/ou ensuite on peut
choisir son parcours comme ça on saura
communiquer et la deuxième chose sur
lequel on attend eric dupond moretti
s'est refus d'aller le plus loin
possible dans une réforme qui est
attendu depuis de nombreuses années en
france et c'est l'autre le statut du
parquet puisque le parquet n'est pas
indépendant du pouvoir exécutif et la
france se fait condamner régulièrement
par la cour européenne des droits de
l'homme pour les soupes bordés et ils
affaires relatives au statut du parquet
donc là dessus on a des progrès à faire
et je pense que on peut penser ce qu'on
veut du personnage je vous dis je vous
donnerai pas mon avis sur le eric dupond
moretti
je vous donne la vie sur mon avis sur un
ministre qui je pense est la bonne
personne pour mener à terme ses réformes
importantes
merci beaucoup entonna un pêcheur
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes avocat et on l'a
appris à midi après les audiences de ce
matin le procès des attentats de janvier
2015 est suspendu jusqu'à vendredi est
l'un des accusés et porter malades plus
de précision avec notre reporter katia
technique présente à la cour d'assises
spéciale de paris
un imprévu s'est produit dans ce procès
qui a été suspendue ce matin lors d'une
audition d'un ancien chef de service de
la dgsi un des onze prévenus a fait un
malaise alors le spectre du coc vide se
profile il faut savoir qu'aucun des
avocats et aucun des prévenus n'a été
attestée jusqu'ici je vous propose
d'écouter jean chevais avocat de la
défense à ce sujet il y a eu une
suspension d'audience parce qu'il ya un
détenu qui est malade qui s'est écroulé
dans la salle c'est à dire que il a été
pris de fièvre
le tremblement de courbatures il a vomi
manifestement on était obligé de
suspendre et la suspicion de kovy de
plane dans tous les esprits bien sûr le
prévenu a été raccompagné à fleury
mérogis pour une série de tests et là
encore des inconnues subsistent
peut-être que le résultat du test covin
ne sera pas prêt demain matin et selon
la maladie ne pourra y avoir aucune
suspension de séance mais par exemple
s'il s'agit du coc vide la poursuite du
procès serait un petit peu incertaine et
cela pourrait avoir de graves
conséquences comme l'expliquent maître
catherine svarc avocate des parties
civiles ce qui va se poser c'est la
question de la détention provisoire des
des accusés
parce que je pense que les demandes de
mise en liberté vont pleuvoir demain si
on apprend qu'il ya une suspension du du
procès pendant quatorze ou quinze jours
ou trois semaines et il faudra complète
il y aura une décision
alors je vous dis pas vous savez moi je
demanderais évidemment qu'il soit
maintenu en détention
évidemment beaucoup de déception car les
témoignages cet après-midi était très
attendu à commencer par celui de peter
chérif djihadistes actuellement
incarcéré à djibouti un mentor des
frères kwasi et puis également celle de
farid benyettou un repenti beaucoup
d'avocats s'interroge sur ces nouvelles
bonnes intentions affichées
il se demande si ce n'est pas lui un des
cerveaux du des attentats de janvier
2015 et dernière audition qui était
prévu et donc bien entendu annuler les
repoussent à une date ultérieure celle
de djamel beghal lui aussi radicaliser
donc toutes ces audiences seront
reportés mais on ne sait pas à quelle
date est pour le moment nous sommes dans
le flou quant à la reprise de ce procès
et dans quelques instants nous
reviendrons sur la visite du ministre
iranien des affaires étrangères java
tarifs à son homologue russe sergueï
lavrov la question syrienne nécessite
une coordination particulière at il
précisé puis nous parlerons de julian
assange la pétition hashtag free assange
de reporters sans frontières et
certaines pages du site internet de
l'organisation subi une attaque en ligne
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
entre 800 et 1000 tonnes de fuel se sont
déversés dans les eaux turquoises
mauricienne ce qu'il faudrait étendre
l'enquète aux autorités portuaires voir
plus haut
nous devrons annoncé une enquête une
fois maintenant établir la chaîne de
responsabilités nationales
il faut savoir que la partie arrière du
bateau contient encore environ 50 à 100
tonnes de fioul
donc ça pourrait aussi actuellement se
fracasser et causé un deuxième
déversement de pétrole plus ça arrive
après les convives 19 ans secteur
hôtelier et touristique est à genoux
l'ensemble des impacts de la catastrophe
sur l'environnement marin mais aussi sur
les populations niveau de la santé vont
se faire ressentir pendant des décennies
il faut s'attendre aujourd'hui à maurice
aussi un désastre sanitaire
il est catastrophe on a vécu voilà
pourquoi je suis pas si pessimiste que
c'est
[Musique]
le 14 juillet 2015 et signe à vienne un
accord de limitation du nucléaire
iranien à sa partie purement civil
contrairement aux engagements de
l'accord signé et respecté par les
iraniens
le président avait décidé de rompre
l'accord et d'imposer son régime de
sanctions au niveau international sur
1000 iran en grave difficulté au plan
économique et social pour la chine c'est
une très belle opportunité
la première question qu'il faut se poser
est lourde de conséquences les iraniens
avaient ils un autre choix face aux
pressions américaines en tous genres par
notre incapacité à répondre à ces
attentes légitimes
nous les avons nous pas pousser dans les
bras d'un partenaire qui va en profiter
pour faire de l'iran
sa tête de pont au moyen orient
le corps n'avait russa a une odeur c'est
pas l'odeur du virus que les chiens
cherche c'est l'odeur de ce que fait le
virus dans l'organisme
c'est quoi le taux de fiabilité du
projet ne sai scoville 10 nas et on
oscille entre 92 et 98 2 5% ça
fonctionne bien ça permet un d'être
rapide d'être non invasif et puis
d'avoir le résultat de façon instantanée
avec un coût qui est quand même bien
moindre plus que sur les coûts actuels
du pcr on va pas sauver l'humanité
souffrent pour révolutionner les choses
avec le travail qu'on fait ou peut-être
faire en sorte qu'on fasse appel à un
savoir faire et un savoir faire médical
aussi dans un domaine un peu différente
et celui de l'animal mais après tout
l'homme c'est un animal peu plus tôt
on vit tous les jours sans faire
attention que tout en dépend c'est
l'unité de mesure de toute chose une
convention admise par tous
s'il arrive quelque chose tout s'arrête
[Applaudissements]
oh
vous conviendrez que c'est l'argent qui
fait tourner le monde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
peu importe que ce soit des bitcoins du
bon vieux cash
nous vous parlerons de tout sans langue
de bois
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez qu'avec cette
candidature a dû pdc y votre parti reste
crédible
à partir du moment où le plaisir et
colombier revire la course
nous allons remettre la côte d'ivoire
sur les rails de la démocratie et
retrouver la cohésion sociale que nous
avons perdu malheureusement on
réellement parler de climat
insurrectionnel en côte d'ivoire si on
permettait aux ivoiriens de manifester
est libre d'exprimer leurs opinions en
toute liberté
il n'y aurait pas de nous allons
retrouver le pouvoir gagner ces
élections et il n'y aura pas de chasse
aux sorcières que les partisans du rhdp
se rassurent nous n'allons pas les
poursuivre on les fautes commises
nous allons véritablement travailler sur
le rétablissement de la cohésion sociale
et une réconciliation vraie d ivoirité
[Musique]
mais
bonsoir et bienvenue sur rt france si
vous nous rejoignez il est 21h30 heure
française
le chef de la diplomatie iranienne
mohammed javad zarif était à moscou où
il a rencontré son homologue russe
sergueï lavrov aujourd'hui au centre des
discussions les récentes sanctions
américaines à l'encontre de téhéran mais
aussi les pressions sur le projet nord
stream 2 elle les détails avec notre
correspondant à moscou antoine gayraud
concernant leur réintroduction de
sanctions américaines contre téhéran
les avis des deux hommes convergent il
s'agit de mesures unilatérales illégal
en contradiction avec le droit
international
le ministre iranien a rappelé la
position du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
qui rejette cette initiative de la part
de washington a aussi profité pour
remercier la russie qui a joué et qui
continue de jouer un rôle clé dans la
sauvegarde de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien
nous avons examiné des questions liées à
l'accord sur le nucléaire iranien en
soulignant un rôle très important
un rôle clé de la russie dans la
préservation de cet accord
face aux efforts illégitime déployés
dans ce domaine par les états unis
il abuse des mécanismes du conseil de
sécurité
on voit que 13 membres du conseil de
sécurité sur 15 sont parvenus à un
consensus sur cette question
ce qui signifie que les états unis ont
échoué bien évidemment la russie et la
chine ont joué un rôle très important
les deux ministres ont aussi évoqué la
situation en syrie en afghanistan mais
l'actualité concernant la sphère navalni
et ses possibles conséquences s'est
invité dans la conférence de presse
ainsi sergueï lavrov a déploré les
réponses parfois absurde de la part de
berlin à la suite des demandes de moscow
et la donner son avis sur la menace de
sanctions qui plane au dessus du gazoduc
nord stream donc au second poteau
en ce qui concerne nord stream 2 je
pense qu'il est temps de suspendre les
discussions à ce sujet nous voyons
comment les états unis essayent tous les
jours du mil
et publiquement l'union européenne il
s'agit surtout de l'allemagne
et comment les états unis par le biais
de leurs porte-paroles exige que
l'allemagne prenne conscience de son
bonheur et de la nécessité de renforcer
sa sécurité énergétique
les états unis veulent dire par là qu'il
faut renoncer à nord stream 2 et passer
au gaz naturel comprimé américain qui
est considérablement plus cher je crois
personnellement c'est mon avis personnel
et ce n'est pas une déclaration
officielle c'est maintenant une question
d'honneur pour la république fédérale
d'allemagne d'honneur au sens littéral
du terme
prochaines dates clés pour les rangs le
18 octobre prochain avec la levée
programmée de l'embargo sur les armes
conventionnelles
conformément aux dispositions de
l'accord de vienne mais voilà encore une
fois les états unis s'y opposent
estimant que cela serait une menace pour
tout le moyen-orient et pourront revenir
sur cette rencontre entre l'iran et la
russie nous sommes avec jarre espierres
analyste géopolitique chercheur associé
à la fée mot c'est la fondation d'études
pour le moyen-orient
gérard vespière bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france alors
concernant les sanctions américaines à
l'encontre de téhéran à l'iran et la
russie sont sur la même ligne
en quoi finalement ces sanctions sont
considérées comme illégales par les deux
pays
écoutez il ya une difficulté sur
l'interprétation de la situation
américaine vis-à-vis de l'accord donc du
14 juillet 2015
les etats unis disent ne pas en être
sorti a et donc de fait de cette
position je dirais intellectuels
politiques stratégiques à avoir droit de
pouvoir à faire intervenir le mécanisme
donc de snapshot c'est-à-dire de remise
en place des sanctions
les autres membres de cet accord disent
bas à partir du moment où vous avez pris
des sanctions déjà contre l'iran c'est
que vous avez dénoncé l'accord donc vous
êtes sorti il ya cette ambiguïté
juridique mais il y
les différences en dehors du juridique
et du politique des différents analyse
stratégique à savoir à l'est l'europe
dis très clairement nous avons un
problème avec l'iran dans la clause donc
de 2025 de cet accord 2025 c'est demain
matin
au delà de 2025 il n'y a rien de prévu
donc travaillons dès maintenant avec
téhéran pourra prévoir quelque chose
deuxièmement nous sommes très soucieux
et inquiète du programme de missiles à
nu potentiellement nucléaire mentent ou
cabalistiques que l'iran est en train de
mettre au point les troisièmement nous
demandons à l'iran de remettre dans ses
casernes à les soldats qui sont en syrie
qui les gardiens de la révolution qui
sont à présent au liban et est aussi on
ira donc il ya des thèmes stratégiques
de désaccord entre l'iran et la et et
l'europe mais sur ce point de vue là
d'un point de vue stratégique
l'europe et les états unis sont très
proches l'un de l'autre
pourquoi la russie a un rôle clé dans la
préservation de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
la russie a premièrement une position
hadj électriquement intéressante elle ne
demande pas à l'iran de revenir dans
l'accord mais de rester dans l'accord
donc quand on dit rester on ne s'exprime
pas sur le fait qu' on en est sorti ou
pas et deuxièmement les relations entre
téhéran et moscou sont son triple a
premièrement il ya des relations de
client à fournisseur à fournisseurs donc
la russie l'est pour l'armement donc
aérien par exemple vis-à-vis de téhéran
deuxièmement elle fournit des
équipements pour les centrales
nucléaires civiles donc les centrales
qui font qu'ils produisent de
l'électricité et il ya donc des liens de
commerce très très fort mais il y assure
le dossier iranien par exemple l'iran et
la russie ont été des alliés jusqu'à
présent mais maintenant on pourrait
presque dire à des ennemis entre
guillemets à kara a dit mi-août chine
dès 2018 a dit que le règlement de ce
dossier syrien ne
rey se faire qu'avec le départ de toutes
les troupes étrangères présentes en
syrie et donc alexandre lavrentiev a
ajouté même les troupes iraniennes donc
là il y a une différence fondamentale
entre les iraniens qui veulent rester en
syrie et donc les les russes qui
souhaite que les iraniens en sorte
vous parlez de la coopération pour les
énergies coopération militaire également
entre la russie et l'iran est ce que la
russie entend mener d'autres coopération
avec l'iran à l'avenir oui pourquoi pas
mais dont kylie a besoin
d'investissements donc c'est pour ça que
téhéran s'est tourné vers pékin n'est ce
pas parce que bon la bourse de pékin est
peut-être un peu plus large et
potentiellement généreuse d'autant plus
que 1 l'iran a été un fournisseur de
pétrole vers la chine donc il y à déjà
là des des liens importants alors que
sur les questions énergétiques et bien à
long terme
un iran et russie sont des concurrents
potentiels n'est ce pas
les réserves de gaz en iran sont les
deuxièmes du monde quatrièmes ou
cinquièmes réserves de pétrole du monde
donc c'est très proche des frontières
européennes pas très loin de la
méditerranée un don qui lie à la à
partir du moment où l'iran pourrait
revendre à nouveau pétrole et gaz a à
l'europe à ce serait peut-être moins de
ventes pour la russie alors le 18
octobre prochain lever programmé pour
l'iran de l'embargo sur les armes
conventionnelles les américains s'y
opposent il parle d' une menace pour le
moyen-orient est ce qu'aujourd'hui
l'iran est une vraie menace pour le
moyen-orient ou pas à gérer un vestiaire
écouté il y à une déstabilisation qui a
commencé depuis 1982 n'est ce pas la
création du hezbollah l'arrivée des
premiers miliciens iraniens remonte à
1982 nous avons tous sont présents
l'esprit la contribution et on en a
parlé iranienne a donc au maintien de
bachar el-assad
l'iran maintient 30 à 35 mille miliciens
payé par téhéran donc des irakiens p
et par téhéran à à bagdad et dans toutes
les principales villes irakiennes
elle a contribué terran a contribué à
armer les outils donc il y a une
capacité déstabilisatrices du
moyen-orient qui est en place depuis de
nombreuses années
merci beaucoup gérard vestiaire pour
votre expertise je rappelle que vous
êtes analyste géopolitique chercheur
associé à la fée mots à la fondation
d'études pour le moyen-orient nouvelles
violences aux états unis après les
charges retenues par la justice dans la
sphère breanna taylor sur les trois
policiers impliqués dans la mort de
cette jeune afro-américaine
seul un agent a été inculpé pour mise en
danger de la vie d'autrui
une décision qui provoque la colère de
la famille debré au nahd taylor et
entraîné de nombreuses manifestations
dans le pays
théo combes c'est une décision de
justice qui était particulièrement
attendu près de six mois après la mort
de briony taylor
le jury du kentucky a décidé d'occuper
seulement un des trois policiers
impliqués dans son décès un choix
particulièrement clément puisque bret
hankinson le seul agent qui sera donc
visée par un procès ne lesquin
directement pour mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui
une décision qui a provoqué plusieurs
rassemblements partout dans le pays
le décès de cette infirmière afro
américaine abattue par huit balles lors
d'une opération anti drogue qui s'était
finalement avérée infructueuse est
devenu un des symboles des luttes
antiracistes aux états unis pour
l'avocat de la famille
le jugement rendu est scandaleux le
grand jury du comté de jefferson inculpé
l'ancien officier bret and kingson avec
trois chefs d'accusation pour mise en
danger injustifiée au premier degré pour
des balles qui sont entrés dans d'autres
appartements mais rien pour le meurtre
de bris au natel or s est scandaleux et
offensants si le comportement de bray
tan kin somme constituait une mise en
danger injustifiée de personnes dans les
appartements voisins
alors il aurait dû en être de même pour
l'appartement de briounas taylor en fait
il aurait dû être considéré comme un
meurtre gratuit
peu après cette inculpation plusieurs
dizaines de manifestations spontanées
ont eu lieu notamment à new york boston
ou encore philadelphie à louiseville là
où réside et brianna taylor
des violences ont émaillé le cortège
deux agents de police ont été blessés
par balles et un suspect a été
interpellé pour le procureur général du
kentucky
daniel cameron la justice a correctement
effectué son travail
je sais que tout le monde ne sera pas
satisfait des chefs d'accusation que
nous avons présentés aujourd'hui mon
équipe a entrepris d'enquêter sur les
circonstances de la mort de mademoiselle
taylor nous l'avons fait avec un
objectif unique en tête la recherche de
la vérité si nous agissons simplement
sur la base de l'émotion ou de
l'indignation
il n'y a pas de justice la justice de la
foule n'est pas la justice la justice
par la violence n'est pas la justice
elle devient simplement une vengeance et
dans notre système
la justice pénale n'est pas la quête de
la vengeance c'est la quête de la vérité
des preuves et des faits et
l'utilisation de cette vérité dans
l'application équitable de nos lois en
orge une décision de justice qui a
également fait réagir la classe
politique américaine le candidat
démocrate à la présidentielle
joe biden a appelé au calme tout en
disant comprendre la frustration des
manifestants deux albums de son côté a
salué le travail effectué par le
procureur du kentucky et annonce prié
pour les deux policiers touchés par
balles à louiseville
reporters sans frontières dénonce une
attaque en ligne contre la pétition free
assange selon reporters sans frontières
aucune donnée n'a été compromise et
l'organisation a pris des mesures
immédiates pour sécuriser son outil de
pétitions rsf pointe du doigt une
tentative délibérée de nuire à la
campagne mais se déclare déterminé à
obtenir la libération du fondateur de
wikileaks et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis londres avec diego
alvarez il est journaliste indépendant
c'est notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
diego alvarez bonsoir merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france je
rappelle que vous allez faire
prochainement un documentaire sur julian
assange vous connaissait
particulièrement bien ce dossier à ces
dizaines de milliers de fausses
signatures ajouté à la pétition quel est
le but qu'est ce qu'on peut comprendre
écouter en effet le 22 septembre
portable sans frontières a pris
connaissance d'une attaque sur son site
internet
datant du 17 septembre et visant
notamment la pétition free assange
bien que l'origine elle mobile précis de
l'attaqué reste inconnu des dizaines de
milliers de signatures ont en effet
falsifiés et en effet été simultanément
rajouter à leur pétition avec de
véritables aiderait simuler le
combinables que non
il semblerait que cette attaque mais
bellion soit une tentative claire de fos
et de discréditer la campagne pour la
liberté de la presse et de saper leurs
efforts en faveur de julian assange qui
est ce qui aurait intérêt à faire ça
d'après vous le gouvernement américain
[Musique]
je sais pas je l'ignorent alors on va on
va revenir peut-être sur la situation de
julian assange
d'après un psychologue qui l'a examinée
le lanceur d'alert souffrirait de
troubles psychologiques aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous avez des informations à
ce sujet tout à fait alors les les trois
derniers jours ont été particulièrement
éprouvants pour la famille et les
proches de julian assange en effet il a
été question durant ces trois derniers
jours de l'état de santé de julian
assange et plusieurs experts ont été
entendus à la barre tels que le docteur
kopelman professeur en neuropsychiatrie
de l'institut de psychiatrie du king's
collège de londres ainsi que le docteur
dit les petits cadre du national health
service notamment spécialisée de
l'autisme ils ont tous de témoigner de
leurs nombreuses visites avec julian
assange et de leur évaluation médicale
notamment au sujet du syndrome
d'asperger heures dont souffrent de
julian assange
à partir de quel moment ces soucis de
santé mentale pour être empêché une
extradition le seysses est prévu ou pas
écoutez le docteur koeman a notamment
déclaré qu'elle songeait avait reçu ce
diagnostic de dépression est du sabreur
et qu'il courrait un risque élevé de
suicides s'il devait être extradé vers
les états unis et que l' isolement qui
livrait aux états unis serait bien pire
que tout ce qu'ils avaient pu vivre à
l'ambassade équateur ou à la prison de
bellemare il serait bon de rappeler
aussi que l'article 21 de la loi sur
l'extradition du royaume uni un père dit
l'extradition si l'état physique ou
mentale de la personne est telle qu'il
serait injuste ou oppressif de
l'extrader et que l'article 3 de la
convention européenne des droits de
l'homme dit que nul ne peut être soumis
à la torture ni à des peines ou à des
traitements inhumains dégradants
quelles sont les chances selon vous que
julian assange ne soit pas extradée
aujourd'hui je pense que les chances
sont extrêmement faibles que jean ce ne
soit pas extrêmement faible part qu'est
ce qui vous fait dire ça aujourd'hui il
semblerait que la décision
et déjà été prises par des juges en fait
comment est ce que vous vous sentez que
les juges ont déjà pris leur décision
on a pu voir que notamment les
différents procureurs essayer de mettre
des mots dans la bouche des experts
comment dire ah oui que oui la queue ils
ont déjà pris leur décision et qu'ils
s'amendent intentions clairement extradé
julian assange
je le disais vous vous préparez un
documentaire sur julian assange
qu'est ce que vous comptez nous vous
nous racontez dans ce documentaire je
conte raconté l'histoire de julian
assange depuis son extradition vers
l'ambassade d'équateur son arrestation à
l'ambassade d'équateur et jusqu'à la fin
de son procès l'extradition en fait
expliqué absolument tout ce qui se passe
qu'est ce que vous avez appris vous qui
n'est pas forcément relayé aujourd'hui
dans la presse c'est à dire est ce que
là lors du tournage de votre
documentaire est ce que vous avez été
marqué par des faits particuliers qu'on
n'entend pas forcément aujourd'hui nous
dans la presse j'ai été marqué par
beaucoup de choses notamment les
conditions de détention dont fait face
actuellement julian assange et la prison
de belles marques et une prison de haute
sécurité
où il est à l'isolément dans une prison
qui a été construite pour les
terroristes aux attentats du 11
septembre
vous avez pu rencontrer ses proches dans
quel état d'esprit sont ils combatif
la plupart de ses proches sont combatifs
espère vraiment que julian assange ne
sera pas extradé vers les états unis
merci beaucoup
diego alvarez d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste indépendant et que vous
préparez un documentaire sur la vie de
julian assange est c'est la fin de cette
émission on se retrouve dans quelques
minutes on fera un point complet sur
l'actualité rester avec nous sur rt
france
[Musique]
dans les banques où la diversité c'est
un autre point fort pas notre point
faible
ce que j'ai vu depuis le 17 octobre et
depuis aussi le 4 août c'est une
mobilisation sociétal qui n'existait pas
avant toutes les confessions se
retrouver sur la place des martyrs un
cercle ohada et tout le monde discute et
finalement que mon discuter ils sont
trouvés entre le même drapeau libanais
pour une fois vous voyez des images
assez touchants de l'armée qui était
presque impliqué avec les manifestants
aujourd'hui on sent que le ton a changé
c'est la cause des hommes politiques et
sont en train de manipuler l'armée on
sait très bien pourquoi ils nous tirent
dessus s'est assis savent que c'est leur
fin ils se préparent le seul langage
qu'ils connaissaient la violence il ne
va pas être violent et on va rester
[Musique]
quelle reprise économique pour l'après
qu'ovide 19 à quoi